del 1969 gli stati uniti spediscono
nello spazio un oggetto un manufatto che
è poco più grande di un elettrodomestico
detto non ci sono tre uomini
quattro giorni dopo
due di questi tre uomini si trovano
all'interno di un veicolo direi
abbastanza sgraziato all'epoca il design
non era previsto nei progetti spaziali
la destinazione era il mare della
tranquillità sulla superficie della luna
il controllo missione che stava a huston
aveva da pochi minuti dato l'okay ad
iniziare la sequenza di all omaggio ad
un certo punto sul display di quello che
era l'interfaccia rudimentale del
computer di bordo si accende una luce
gialla lampeggiante che indicava
ovviamente un errore e iniziano a
comparire dei codici in quel momento le
trasmissioni erano in diretta mondiale
erano in chiaro non c'è la crittografia
e quindi si può sentire la voce del
comandante del modulo lunare armstrong
che con una voce tra il preoccupato il
concitato anzi direi brusca chiede a
huston
abbiamo un errore il 12 0 2
lì per lì non viene data risposta a cui
insiste che dobbiamo fare con il 12 0 2
sul controllo missione c'era questo
signore steve hayles è il sovrintendente
alla parte che riguardava il sistema di
allunaggio perché il computer quel
momento sovrintendeva queste operazioni
lui come la procedura solleva
l'interfono e si mette in contatto con
quest'altro giovane ingegnere gel
karmann che all'epoca aveva soltanto 24
anni
garman era il responsabile dello
sviluppo di quella parte di software che
in quel momento stava dando l'errore il
12 02 era un errore dovuto al
sovraccarico del sistema per un motivo
ignoto in quel momento il computer di
bordo aveva troppe cose da fare e quindi
continuava a presentarsi ora perché
questo non fosse mai accaduto durante le
simulazioni non era dato saperlo garman
doveva prendere una di quelle decisioni
che cambiano un po il corso della storia
poteva dare il segnale che la missione
doveva essere abortita in questo modo
avrebbe deluso le aspettative di mezzo
pianeta che era in attesa ma soprattutto
le aspettative di superiorità
tecnologica degli stati uniti oppure
autorizzare il proseguo della missione e
ovviamente rischiando lo schianto del
modulo lunare sulla superficie della
luna con tutte le conseguenze
inimmaginabili che potete pensare
garman impiegò soltanto pochi secondi
per decidere che il suo software era
stato progettato per gestire anche quel
tipo di situazione e che avrebbe portato
felicemente il modulo alla sua sequenza
di atterraggio quindi di ed ergo il suo
supervisore comunicato agli astronauti e
la fine di questa storia la conosciamo
tutti fu un grande successo
l'uomo era sbarcato sulla luna ha
soprattutto gli stati uniti avevano
dimostrato la loro superiorità
tecnologica
si tratta di un fattore umano importante
jackie che harman e stato l'uomo giusto
al posto giusto per prendere una
decisione una valutazione che nel 1969
sicuramente non poteva essere demandata
ad una macchina però per tutti fu un
successo anche della tecnologia il senso
comune era che eravamo sbarcati sulla
luna grazie al computer questa
meraviglia tecnologica l'era spaziale è
la partita e va bene nel 1969 avevamo
contato sul fattore umano che vuol dire
un po sulla fortuna qualcuno pensava che
le chance di successo fossero del 50 per
cento più o meno però ora che i progetti
spaziali erano una realtà e si cominciò
andare nello spazio in maniera quasi di
routine
non potevamo più confidare sul fattore
umano
i progetti erano complessi e quindi si
doveva trovare un modo per gestire
questa complessità con i progetti
spaziali di fine anni settanta e tutti
gli anni 80 si svilupparono infatti
quelle metodologie che riguardavano la
gestione dei progetti complessi ma
soprattutto si gettarono le basi per
quelli che erano i sistemi di controllo
della qualità proprio in quegli anni
nacquero quelle prescrizioni che più
tardi sarebbero state codificate nella
serie iso 9001 che sono delle
prescrizioni su come deve essere
organizzato un progetto complesso per
garantire la qualità del prodotto finale
alla fine degli anni 80 in particolare
nell 87 la prima edizione dell'isola
2001 è pronta ed è pubblicata è un
insieme di norme che spiega come deve
essere condotto un processo complesso il
fattore umano è imbrigliato nella
burocrazia
il processo è diviso in fasi c'è prima
analisi dei requisiti per la
progettazione e poi c'è la parte di
sviluppo poi il teste eccetera ogni fase
deve essere sottoposta al riesame dopo
il riesame c'è una fase di verifica e
dopo la verifica e validazione le
persone che fanno riesame non devono
coinvolte nella progettazione quelli che
fanno la verifica non devono essere
coinvolti nelle fasi precedenti eccetera
eccetera
montagne di documenti un mare di
burocrazia l'uomo ridotto a soggetto che
si assume la sua responsabilità formale
rispetto a queste carte e mette la sua
firma
né 87 lì sono 2001 è pubblicato è il
primo progetto spaziale ma credo che sia
stato anche il primo progetto in
assoluto ad essere realizzato
nell'ambito di un sistema certificato vi
sono venire uno certificato con dire che
un ente indipendente
garantiva che queste norme erano
rispettate fu un progetto europeo il
progetto del razzo ariane 5 la quinta
generazione del vettore europeo
il primo prodotto uscito da un sistema
certificato iso 9001 e 4 giugno del 1996
il primo esemplare di razzo ariane 5 si
trovava sulla rampa di lancio pronto a
partire e questa volta nessuno degli
uomini che stava nella sala controllo
avrebbe dovuto prendere una di quelle
decisioni di quelle che toccarono ad
esempio al nostro jack garman è infatti
fu direttamente il computer in piena
autonomia che 37 secondi dopo il lancio
avviò la sequenza di autodistruzione
mandando in fumo il razzo arianna ma
soprattutto il suo prezioso carico dei
satelliti e strumentazioni elettroniche
per un valore stimato di circa
337 milioni di dollari anche in questo
caso si trattò di un errore del software
un air one anche abbastanza
banale ma negli anni avvenire fu noto
come il mago del software più costoso
della storia
il problema ovviamente
fu attribuito alla ancora imperfezione
del sistema qualità probabilmente le
maglie non erano ancora troppo strette e
quindi si continua a introdurre
burocrazia a fare grosse sempre più
complesse ci voleva altri due disastri
spaziali e chissà quanti progetti
falliti tutto il mondo per capire un
fatto fondamentale la complessità non
può essere esente da difetti gli errori
sono il fatto connaturato alla
complessità del sistema lo sviluppo del
software in particolare un'attività in
complessa e quindi inevitabilmente
quando si progetta il software alla fine
dentro si lasceranno degli errori il
problema è che avevamo sbagliato fino a
quel momento abbiamo cercato di
sostituire la burocrazia per governare
il fattore umano
tentando di eliminare gli errori dalla
complessità invece dovevamo ribaltare
completamente il punto di vista
bisognava puntare sul fattore umano per
mitigare gli effetti di questa
inevitabile complessità e così
all'inizio del nuovo millennio di volare
nel 2002 fu pubblicato nella comunità
degli ingegneri che si occupano di
metodologie di sviluppo del software
quello che è noto come il manifesto
dello sviluppo agile da questo manifesto
da cui nascono alcuni principi sono
uscite fuori tutte le metodologie che
adesso vanno di moda che hanno nomi
esoterici come scrum lin gamba cose di
questo tipo però al di là del nome
la cosa che caratterizza queste
metodologie è il ribaltamento rispetto
al punto di vista precedente adesso si
mette al centro dottore creativo cioè
l'uomo gli individui le interazioni che
ci sono delle persone che sono più
importanti dei processi e delle
tecnologie che vengono utilizzate non
più documentazione comprensiva in
comunicazione estesa ma software che
deve funzionare
ecco tutta l'innovazione del nuovo
millennio e soprattutto tutta quella
innovazione che oggi chiamiamo
transizione 4.0 è figlia di questo modo
di procedere oggi si lavora con l'uomo
al centro del processo creativo ecco un
luogo dove tutto questo può essere visto
in azione si trova proprio a vicino ai
fab lab ostiense
utilizzando una terminologia e adesso va
di moda lo potremmo chiamare un digital
innovation hub però al di là del nome
che vogliamo darle è un posto dove
dentro di tecnologia ce n'è tanta è un
progetto che ormai a circa 9 anni di
vita la sede del boss ts del 2019 il
progetto è nato prima è tutta questa
tecnologia che sta qui dentro questo
grande assortimento di tecnologia è
stata in qualche modo pensato con
l'obiettivo specifico
creare una infrastruttura in questo caso
questo laboratorio
dove fosse possibile
costruire qualunque tipo di oggetto dal
soprammobile alla sonda spaziale in
effetti noi nel corso degli anni abbiamo
fabbricato dei soprammobili ma abbiamo
fabbricato anche delle sonde spaziali
certo non è che abbiamo mandato degli
oggetti nello spazio profondo e in
questo momento non è che c'è un rover
fabbricato poiché si trova sulla
superficie di marte però questa immagine
è realmente un immagine che si riferisce
ad uno dei nostri progetti
attaccato a quel pallone aerostatico c'è
una sonda con degli strumenti
scientifici per degli esperimenti e
questo esperimento un bel giro nella
stratosfera questa sonda se n'è fatta
certo la stratosfera non è propriamente
lo spazio profondo però avere una
infrastruttura che è in grado di
realizzare oggetti stratosferici con la
stessa facilità con cui si fanno i
soprammobili non è cosa da poco
le tecnologie come vi dicevo sono tanti
abbiamo macchine da stampa di tipo
industriale
abbiamo un laboratorio di prototipazione
elettronica strumenti come il
microscopio metallo grafico che può
essere utilizzato oltre che per studiare
i nuovi materiali per provare per
esempio i chip di silicio nella fase
iniziale della progettazione
stampanti 3d ovviamente
macchine da taglio una curatrice una
serie che apparecchi che probabilmente
anche noi abbiamo perso memoria ora
perché un tempo avevamo in questa
telecamera ad alta velocità mi sfugge
però comunque di tecnologia ce ne è
veramente tanta e questo ovviamente
l'esistenza di questo laboratorio
incuriosisce e abbiamo spesso richieste
di visita di solito quando ci chiedono
di visitare il laboratorio
sia un'istituzione un giornalista un
politico molto spesso gente comune quasi
sempre nella mail c'è la richiesta di
una appuntamento per venire a visitare
le macchine loro vengono a visitare le
macchine non noi
la visita di cortesia che sul
laboratorio però dopo che hanno fatto il
giro
se poi tu chiedi a queste persone che
sono venute cos'è che a pressione del
laboratorio cioè la cosa ti ha colpito
della visita quasi sempre rispondono che
la cosa più affascinante che hanno
trovato all'interno del laboratorio al
di là della tecnologia è sicuramente il
suo effetto lo fa sono le persone ecco
le persone sono la parte più importante
del laboratorio la cosa che colpisce è
che sono molto eterogenei tra loro per
tipo di professionalità anche per
curriculum non vi immaginereste
ritrovare persone di tipo così diverso
nella stessa struttura e soprattutto a
lavorare alternandosi sulle stesse
postazioni tanto per fare una carrellata
potete trovare dei programmatori questo
è un team di sviluppatori software
ovviamente sono contenti perché hanno
appena trovato un vagone loro software
attività principale del programmatore
questa possiamo avere una designer
famosa pendente i suoi prodotti in tutto
il mondo che sta scegliendo dei
materiali innovativi per la sua prossima
collezione di gioielli oppure
sperimentate le tecnologie innovative
per materiali convenzionali
possiamo trovare un ricercatore
universitario quello che va portato la
fotocamera ad alta velocità che lavora
accanto ad una giovane stilista che sta
completando la sua collezione perché tra
qualche giorno magari andrà in
passerella
abbiamo un artista famoso che produce
opere utilizzando l'elettronica ecco a
questo proposito vi sono opere d'arte
nate nel nostro storico che sono
presenti in molti musei arte
contemporanea tutto il mondo soltanto a
roma abbiamo veri alla galleria
nazionale d'arte moderna
abbiamo avere al maxxi abbiamo avere
dentro la collezione permanente della
farnesina
possiamo avere un designer industriale
che sta
impegnato nella nello sviluppo del
prototipo del prodotto che appena
concepito
possiamo trovare un imprenditrice in
erba che sta sperimentando un nuovo
processo per produrre bio plastiche che
sarà poi l'elemento fondante della sua
start up innovative
possiamo trovare un'azienda storica
romana che è impegnata a sperimentare
nuovi processi produttivi per i suoi
prodotti artigianali quello che però è
una caratteristica che accomuna tutti
quanti e che normalmente quando sono
presenti nel laboratorio appaiono
contenti questa è una cosa che hai
scelto spesso il visitatore nota qui
sorridono tutti ecco se tu chiedi alle
persone perché poi parlando lì dentro
ovviamente l'interazione è quello di
farsi raccontare le cose perché queste
persone sono felici perché si sentono
loro dicono più ispirate hanno
l'impressione di essere più creative
quando lavorano nel laboratorio
questo non è un caso perché in realtà il
laboratorio è stato specificamente
progettato
in modo da rendere più creative e le
persone la metafora che noi abbiamo
utilizzato è quella del banco
dell'artigiano parco della reggiana ha
fatto da tanti strumenti semplici al
centro c'è il soggetto operativo e con
la stessa semplicità prende un martello
un altro tipo di strumento che sono
semplicemente degli elementi che
potenziano la sua anche reattività
il nostro modello di tecnologia infatti
è proprio questo nella nostra idea la
tecnologia non sostituisce l'uomo male
stent e grazie
[Applauso]